i i definitely have to start with
does it ever get old people wanting to
talk about uh tammy taylor
and uh friday night lights no
because i love tammy taylor and friday
night lights so you know
i could kind of talk about it and i'm
just like i'm just realizing that it's
been 15 years
which i can't believe um but yeah i
still
i still i still learn from that
experience
i'm always going back to that experience
and
you know acts trying to access some of
the things that some of the experience
some some of the
just great distinct styles of the way we
shot and the way we worked and
it was really special yeah i loved that
show
and uh uh yeah i have nothing but
positive things to say
about watching that series um jumping
into why i get to talk to you today
because i could talk about friday night
lights the entire time
what was it about the script and story
of this project that said i want to do
this
well i i remember actually
reading about joe bell and his walk
across america
in the news like when it happened years
ago
and so when i read the script i thought
this would be such a great
opportunity to actually get inside
this story and understand
something that i feel is a very is a
very universal
idea of um
you know parents understanding their
lgbtq children
also of communities
uh understanding better and being
inclusive
and you know i think by
really getting into the nuance of
who these people are understanding that
they were just
we can they're just like us you know
they're just parents
who love their child and are doing the
best they can
and um that i think it can make a
difference i think that people can watch
this movie and
and really uh make a change
i hope that happens um uh films like
this are incredibly important
shining a light on such an important
issue um yeah i love learning about the
behind the scenes of the making of a
movie
um is there anything that you think
might surprise people to learn about the
making of this film
you know one of the i guess one of the
most impactful things about making the
movie to me
was that i was i had the opportunity to
speak to lola who is the character that
i play
and um that was
really incredible and uh
illuminating because it was her
perspective
on her husband and on her son that i
think
really sort of impacted
the way we were able to tell the story
so and for me frankly like
just to be able to sit down with a woman
who had gone through that kind of
tragedy
and say who are you like
how do you where does your strength come
from how do you do this
um to me that was that was a pretty
extraordinary experience
i have to stop there i'm just going to
say congrats on your work on this film
i wish you nothing but the best thank
you stephen i appreciate it